hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Chapter five of the categories
Aristotle spends a good bit of space
discussing the relationship between
species and genus or the at least this
is how we're translating those terms a
dose and gain oh so you notice that gain
OS and genus are quite close together a
dose is the Greek for the the form of
things or the type of things translated
in Latin by spake EA's so that that's
why we have the word species there and
these are showing up quite a lot not
only in the categories but also in in
other works by Aristotle particularly
where he's needing to differentiate
classes of things from each other I want
to say from the start that this is not
exactly the same thing as what you might
have been introduced to in a biology
class or an earth science class where
you you learn these terms species genus
and then you learn all sorts of other
things above them as other classify
kateri levels all the way up to say
Kingdom right where we have animal
vegetable and then whatever else and
sometimes they change over time whatever
else we want to place in there now it's
not to say that it's
totally disconnected from that and that
class of the Katori scheme that we use
today did in part come out of distant
origins in Aristotle's work but what's
important to keep in mind is that
although species might more or less
correspond to what we nowadays call of
species genus just means all these other
classes of things classes of species
that can be arranged in a hierarchy so
everything from you know genus all the
way up to kingdom would be a speed would
be a genus in Aristotelian parlance so
whatever baggage you're bringing from
you know what you've learned in in
modern science classes you probably want
to set that aside at least for
understanding what Aristotle means by
species and genus in his categories it's
not to say that it's wrong or anything
like that it's just not going to be
particularly helpful I think so what
will be helpful well realizing from the
beginning that work what we're talking
about our classes or kinds or
associations of things and we can
understand things here in two different
ways I mentioned that genus is you know
associating different species together
the species is is closer so when we say
for example human being or horse those
are examples of species and you know
nowadays we might acknowledge well
there's subspecies you know and we tend
to base it on whether the the species
the members of the species can
successfully breed with each other and
and produce offspring Aristotle is
primarily interested in associating
things under the same linguistic and
mental rubric in terms of having the
same basic type of being so human and
horse would be examples of a day you
know the plural for a dose species
animal would be a much higher level and
there it's it's not just extending to
all the individual things that we call
animal
it's including
the different classes or species so
horse and human cockroach
you know potato bug or some people call
them Rolie polies or things like that
all of these would be examples of
animals right and their species would
fall into that higher class of things
where the things are indeed the species
and Aristotle will go on to say that the
relationship between individual thing
and species is along the same lines as
the relationship between species and and
genus so he also talks about these in
terms of secondary substance if that's
confusing you probably want to watch the
discussion of primary and secondary
substance which covers some of the same
ground now here what we're particularly
interested in is that these are
secondary substances these are not
substances in their own right as a
matter of fact Aristotle says that if
you don't have any any humans that you
don't have the species of human anymore
right I suppose you could index it to
the Past and say when we're talking
about extinct species that we are
talking about the class of things that
used to exist right like various
dinosaurs or you know trail bites or
interesting things along those lines you
know plants that that no longer exist
anymore as well but anyway secondary
substances he says that these alone
among the various kinds of predicates
define or show and the word that he has
there is a de Lloyd they they display
they they denote you might say primary
substances so when we're using the word
horse of individual existing horses or
perhaps even imaginary horses or past
horses that no longer exist or future
horses that are yet hopefully to come we
are we are using the term to pick out
something that they
you know they share a common nature
their hoarseness if you like it or
humanity is what we use in terms of
human beings so they show it sometimes
this you know define is how it's
translated but perhaps show or to note
is a better way of talking about it so
you know what are the primary substances
individual things right we could use
examples here chalk the word chalk is
used of each of these individual bits of
chalk all of which were at one point
much longer right they're all the same
substance - and we could we could do
similarly of human being me and you we
both if you're a human being that's some
some somebody's dog or cat watching it
or some alien then we all fit under this
this general term and were associated in
that now notice what Aris levels saying
here this this connects with something
else that he was talking about earlier
on we predicate species and genus of
individual things so we can point at me
and say human being we can also point at
me and say horse falsely predicating
that of me we can point at me and say
animal that's at a higher level of
abstraction right saying human being as
Aristotle points out is more informative
than saying just animal say animal then
you know there's certain characteristics
like well we expect me to be eating
eliminating reproducing moving around
from place to place doing certain things
like sensing not all animals necessarily
do all these things to the same extent
some actually remain in place once
they're fixed and and stay there for
life but you get the idea locomotion
might be less essential to animal than
is respiration or or nutrition or
however we want to think about these
things but this is something that's
being predicated and it's not being
predicated in the same way
as saying for example that I am wearing
a shirt in time that would be like the
category of you know possession or state
that we we talked about in Aristotle's
categories it's not the same thing as
saying that I am a father that's a
relational term that's a category of
relation Prost heap it's not the same
thing as saying I am a middle-aged male
right although that's you know pretty
that's getting a lot closer to the core
than the fact that I'm wearing a shirt
and tie it's still not something that's
absolutely you know essential in the
same way that saying I'm human is for
Aristotle male debatable for Aristotle
middle-age definitely not I was young
once I'll be older soon and middle-age
is just something I'm passing through so
these are the predicates that show us
what the individual things are this is
why he will say that what we're able to
predicate of the individual thing is
both the name the ona MA and the
definition definition we want to be a
little bit careful with there that's one
way to translate a statement
meaning statement of its what it is to
be that thing the statement of its
substance calling a person a human being
is denoting certain things of them for
for example for Aristotle rational
rational animal is the you know way in
which animals the genus rationals the
differentia
and the species is rational animal human
being
rationality would be something that
would be of my essence what it means for
me to be a human being
so these are very important kinds of
predicates and that is what we do when
we say that something is this kind of
thing or we ask is is this this sort of
thing or this sort of thing is this an
animal well we start looking for the
characteristics that animals have right
we decide for example that you know
mushrooms are fungi rather than animal
another thing that Aristotle says it's
quite important is that genus and
species are not present in a subject
although they are predicated of a
subject so they're not predicated of
primary substances as Aristotle says
we're not saying that humanity exists
inside of the individual human being we
are predicating human of the human being
precisely because the individual human
being is not just sort of a receptacle
that humanity is poured into although
sometimes it may seem like with children
perhaps right whether the rather
metaphorical way of talking about the
process of maturation and acquiring
rationality but the point is in you know
the individual thing has its nature a
nature that it shares with other
individual things of the same species
but the species itself is not in the
individual human being or horse or
mushroom of this sort or you know
whatever else we want to pick so it's
not in a subject but it is predicated of
a subject the last thing that I think is
particularly important to drive home is
that substances Aristotle says and
differentia those are the things that we
use to differentiate different species
for example from each other right animal
but rational animal the dog not a
rational animal different kind of animal
so the the substances are predicated you
nificantly you nificantly that is to say
that when we say human of me we're not
saying human in a different sense than
we're saying human of you or some other
human being and if we want to try to
extend the term human to something else
like for example if we're considering
whether a eyes
be called human or not or classed as a
different type of thing we want the
predication to not be metaphorical in
the sense of being sort of just
derivative or equivocal where things
mean different they have different
meanings we want it to be one single
core meaning that stays the same that is
stable across the the entire class of
things so for example we've used the the
example of seal if you're going to talk
about the species seal you wouldn't want
to include in that the the contemporary
singer seal who is a human being better
described as human being right he has
the same name but does not have the same
definition as the creature that you know
swims on the scene goes or you know and
and eats fish and I don't know what else
they do play around you know quite a bit
different kind of individual substance
seal versus seal that would be an
example of equivocal predication we
don't want that when we're talking about
species and geniuses they are predicated
UNIF eclis so hopefully that sorts out
all this discussion that you're going to
see in the categories about species in
gs I want to stress one more time
species applies to individual things
genus is any sort of associating class
above that in the hierarchy that takes
different species and orders them in
relation to each other as part of a
group so human being horse animal